alors martine michel sellem buzzati
bonsoir bonsoir journée s'est bousculé
en après midi on a dû changer de sujet
mille fois mais je fais très bonne et
les tic je fais entendre madame enghelab
chef du parti libéral du québec qui
vient de réagir et monsieur legault qui
a réagi tout à l'heure on écoute
aujourd'hui le premier ministre a
confirmé qu'il y avait deux codes
d'éthique un code d'éthique pour les 124
députés et un code d'éthique pour le
ministre steven si le premier ministre
avait été dans l'opposition
est ce qu'il aurait toléré une situation
semblable à mon avis il n'y a qu'une
chose à faire il faut que le ministre de
l'économie se retire temporairement
c'est pas normal qu'une personne qui
détiennent des placements les
entreprises privées déplacement qu'elle
sept personnes optent peuvent vendre
qu'il puisse porter cv qu'elle fût sport
ni travaillé au gouvernement qu'ils
puissent tous être ministre de
l'économie martin biron
ben je pense que le premier ministre
n'aura pas la fin de session dont il
aurait rêvé il va être placé sur la
défensive jusqu'à la fin par les partis
d'opposition sur un thème qui lui est
très cher c'est à dire le thème de
l'éthique et c'est vrai ce que dit
monsieur legault il en fait répété ce
qu'il avait dit au début du mandat y
avait 10 et c'est exactement ça il
faudrait qu'on fasse quelque chose pour
les gens d'affaires qui veut se
présenter en politique et qui ont des
intérêts dans des sociétés privées et
donc qui n'ont pas de lien avec lui
n'ont pas nécessairement de contrat avec
le gouvernement
le problème c'est qu'il n'a rien fait il
le dit alors il s'est rien passé si bien
qu'ils se retrouvent deux ans plus tard
n'a pas changé de camp elle a changé le
temps changeait code les règles sont là
elles existent hélas il met tout son
poids politique des ya derrière un
ministre très important au sein de ce
gouvernement là mais plus encore
derrière les amis personnels michel sait
pas ce qu'il a pu lui poser trois quatre
fois la même question à monsieur fait
ben on a l'impression qu'on dit bon ben
la loi est là mais là ça nous arrange
pas à ce moment alors on ne va pas la
suivre en même temps
l'argumentaire de dire on veut attirer
des gens d'affaires en politique il est
là aussi la la c'est un équilibre
oui mais minutes c'est plus troublant
xxe patrice quand on lit le rapport la
commissaire est obligé de celle que
trouvé qu'il y avait des compagnies
monsieur fils jaden qui n'avait pas été
déclarée dans sa déclaration d'intérêts
donc ils à cacher quelque chose à un
moment donné une ces combines est
suffisamment importante pour faire des
affaires avec investissement québec
représente d'experts indépendants ou un
triplex là il a appelé à investissement
québec ne fait pas faire avec ma
compagnie ça va mettre dans le trou
c'est ces genres de choses qui sont
tolérable la commissaire michel
spécifiquement sur cet aspect là lui
avaient dit pas appelé alors y'a plein
de mots à la transparence envers là
comme ça sa déclaration initiale
c'était vraiment arrangé que le gars des
vues alors c'est ça qui trouve la s400
dire oui mais je pense qu'on pouvait pas
vendre puis pourquoi tu as caché alors
et et c'est ce qui va faire mal et le
chu leveaux et mais je fais des bonnes
si ça continue cette histoire là parce
que c'est un manque de transparence au
départ de l'histoire et les règles qui
sont en cause c'est la volonté mais en
même temps je me fais l'avocat du diable
je pose la question hélène mais sûrement
nous ça nous fait penser à l'histoire de
monsieur arnaud à tahoua des gens qui
ont des carrières dans le monde des
affaires qui sont très riches les fronts
personne fait petite île mais qui ont
envie de servir faire de la politique et
il se retrouve avec un règlement qui est
celle applicable ou pas pour un
ce règlement a lancé sur la question est
là oui oui c'est exactement la question
moi ce qui me frappe quand même quand je
regarde au niveau macro sait à quel
point
peut-être qu est-ce que monsieur fait
des bonnes affaires et peut-être un peu
plus grave que ce que monsieur morneau a
fait mais je pense que le piment il s'en
est mieux sorti parce que cette façon
qu'ils ont eue le de faire une
conférence de presse conjointe hui le
premier ministre passé en détail le
rapport expliqué
c'est quoi leur justification pourquoi
ils sont d'accord pourquoi ils sont pas
d'accord ça peut convaincre que je
pouvais je crois bien des gens dire ok
ben on va passer l'épongé et je compare
ça à l'attitude à ottawa de monsieur
trudeau et monsieur mono ou tout a été
confus encore une fois on sent des
tenues beaucoup à des lignes de
communication qui était pas très claires
et en bout de piste monsieur mort non il
est parti je compare donc de manière
macro je trouve qu'à québec on semble
gérer ça beaucoup mieux car donc
rapidement parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
sujets effectivement martinez qu'un ça
va tenir la route comment l'opposition
va demander son départ bien sûr mais est
ce que à terme ils sont ok avec ça
aujourd'hui mais c'est le 2
un rapport de la commissaire à l'éthique
et à la déontologie c'est pas rien le
premier on l'a blanc mais le premier
ministre a décidé d'acheter la paix
politique le deuxième il décide de le
défendre de se placer derrière c'est sûr
que le blâmant une première fois en
acceptant qu'ils soient blancs mai par
l'assemblée nationale une première fois
il
il a acheté la paix mais sa tâche est un
peu sa relation avec son ministre mais
cette fois ci il met vraiment tout son
poids politique et ça va être
excessivement 10
il faut qu'ils livrent sur le changement
du code éthique là faut qu'on arrive
avec un comité avec tous les partis un
savon sans savoir que tu sais les
d'autre part ce rapport là et plus et
ben là je fais une façon bien plus
sérieuse que le premier alors si
monsieur monsieur leveaux se met
derrière lui dis ça sinon vous voit
jamais attiré le genre d'affaires en
politique il faudrait il ya d'autres
gens d'affaires dans le gouvernement de
monsieur rubio pas de problème avec la
commissaire à l'éthique
alors un moment donné il faudra qu mode
et tout ça puis il faudrait que leur
position soit d'accord vous
imaginez-vous québec solidaire est
d'accord avec source proche du staff est
très bien on pas besoin de réponses
confinement du québec je vends un tel
monsieur legault qui n'exclut rien mais
bon c'est pas pour demain matin mais il
ya des choses très inquiétante quand
même dans les hôpitaux dans les reports
d'opérations en écouter ce que je
demande à toutes les entreprises
les dirigeants des entreprises du québec
c'est de voir pendant le temps des fêtes
s'ils sont capables entre autres du 17
décembre au 4 janvier d'abord de faire
le plus de télétravail possible les
entreprises celles qui sont capables de
fermer de fermer on en discute avec la
santé publique on n'exclut rien
on n'exclut rien martin mais ce qui
préoccupe c'est l'annulation de
plusieurs opérations de plusieurs rendez
vous médicaux bon il a évidemment à
tourriers la question du délestage la
sauce est une des premières choses
d'ailleurs l'écho se tiennent bien en
haut de 2500 par jour ce qui laisse
entendre que les hospitalisations
devrait augmenter dans les prochaines
semaines si la première chose la
deuxième chose est ce qu'on recompte
fine comme certains scientifiques ont
demandé au gouvernement
monsieur le goût et pas très chaud à
cette idée là il ya des facteurs
atténuants c'est à dire que les écoles
vont être fermées donc déjà il ya un
facteur il ya un problème de contagion
important qui va être endiguée pour
cette période là si les entreprises
écoute l'appel de monsieur legault et se
place en télétravail déjà il va voir -
d'éclosion mais ferme est confiné l'on
pense au commerce on pense aux centres
commerciaux mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec les centres de ski qu'est ce qu'on
fait et il ya différents trucs qui sont
ouverts alors ça devient un nouveau
casse tête pendant la période par l
homme et on va essayer de pas aller là
mais la décision est tout il dit tout
n'est pas exclue il reste quand même une
semaine mais c'est un flottement qui
fait qui peut faire la faire ou si
michel parce que on dit aux gens soyez
sérieux parce que c'est ce qui peut
arriver éventuellement oui mais bientôt
la question qui va se poser parce que
les chiffres de best of qui baissent
contrat de façon dramatique d'ici noël
bientôt la question que beaucoup de gens
vont poser dans le milieu de la santé
publique entre autres c est ce qu on
n'est pas mieux de fermer dans les deux
semaines ou de toute façon il ya peu
d'activités économiques que de fermer un
mois au mois de janvier ou de février
ça va être ça la question qui va se
poser parce que ça vos problèmes et est
hélas contrairement à la la première
vague ne sais pas le québec qui fait
cavalier seul en ayant les pires
résultats du canada s'est fixé c'est
effrayant partout puis c'est pire dans
certaines autres provinces alors il faut
faire quelque chose c'est évident et
peut-être que le moindre mal c'est les
semaines de défaites ou le plus
d'activité économique et il ya même déjà
qu'ils se fassent ans hélène l'état
d'esprit ottawa face à dr femmes et
compagnes l'état d'esprit face
aux prochaines semaines qui s'en
viennent mais écoutez monsieur trudeau a
toujours été celui le dirigeant le plus
comment pourrais je dire le plus prudent
probablement parce qu'il nous faut à
défendre ces mesures c'est pas lui qui
doit aller consoler si vous voulez les
écoles ou les commerces qui doivent
fermer alors il a toujours eu cette
attitude beaucoup plus de prudence que
les autres premiers ministres et mais
monsieur trudeau il est toujours en
retenue il sait qu'il ne doit pas avoir
l'air de donner de faire la leçon aux
provinces parce que justement ce n'est
pas ça des sacs sa décision ce n'est pas
à lui de dicter quoi faire mais on le
sent qu'il ronge son frein qu'il
aimerait donc les provinces mettre les
bouchées doubles notamment parce que
c'est lui en grande partie qui écope de
la facture après coup on leur en parler
jeudi le avec la rencontre sol et le
financement des systèmes de santé
oui c'est une grosse rencontre je le dis
aux fumées évidemment von roll train
d'en parler en long et en large un petit
extrait d'une nouvelle approche
publicitaire du gouvernement du québec
face à la coved en écoute
quand le plus dingue compenser ça change
l'eau plein mes a des bons côtés fred
sous la main du mini maison
sa maman n'a aucun ami ont surtout bon
genre de combat tout assez tell my
theresa may not allowed il propose une
pratique et à face de nicolas baulieu
mais surtout parce que le plus beau
cadeau c'est la santé cette année en
fait chacun chez soi non comment le
facteur ma faim va mener mes cadeaux
[Musique]
parce que martin sur le monsieur là
qu'avaient la trachéotomie là on a
beaucoup beaucoup vu à laon charge de
ces véronique prince que ce reportage le
conte vous présentera 18 ans on change
de stratégie web on veut un peu allégé
le climat est remonté le moral on sait
que c'est difficile c'est temps des
fêtes m'ont vu que les gens suivent les
consignes c'est sûr que le monsieur avec
la trachéotomie élèves s'étaient c'était
lourd et c'était pas très festif alors
l'on ose ebay dès qu'on pourra avoir un
ton plus léger et justement à lui j'ai
le moral des gens en leur disant suivi
les consignes avec un sourire
on va suivre ce reportage de véronique
prince plus tard la nouvelle loi pour le
l'aide médicale à mourir on écoute un
extrait de monsieur euro tous les ans
vient tout de suite
je sais que les deux côtés de ce débat
bien sont bien intentionnées mais je
crains que le projet de loi soit 1
première brèche dans le valeur que nous
accordons à la vie c'est une pente
glissante que nous ne devons pas
emprunter avec une loi aussi vague et
sans cercueil
hélène le parti conservateur va tout
faire pour retarder l'adoption de cette
nouvelle loi qui a été demandé par un
jugement
ils ont jusqu'à la mi décembre qu'elle
comment voyez la suite des choses là bas
écoutez ça va bloquer le ministre de la
justice n'a pas d'autre choix soit
qu'ils imposent un bâillon à la chambre
pour que ça aille plus vite demande à la
cour de prolonger une nouvelle est donc
d'offrir une nouvelle échéance
ou peut-être de prolonger les travaux à
la chambre des communes pour qu'on
réussisse à respecter le délai
clairement ses contingents pro vie du
parti conservateur qui est derrière
toute cette initiative ce sont des gens
qui disent vouloir protéger les
personnes les plus vulnérables en
empêchant le premier large island à
mourir aux personnes qui ne sont pas
déjà mourante
mais dans les faits ces députés là
étaient opposés à l'aide médicale à
mourir en partant donc il voit l'un peut
leur intention monsieur o'toole raison
de dire que c'est un débat important
mais il oublie que lors de la première
loi
on avait déjà eu tout ce débat là moi
j'ai rien entendu à date dans toutes ces
discussions ces débats qui était
véritablement nouveau alors un moment
donné on a été bouclé le set des bonnes
mais on peut nous dire ça michel c non
monsieur on oublie une chose c'est que
être trop choix c'est pro-choix penche
sur la question de l'avortement la pro
vie si on est pro vie sur sur cette
question-là de l'aide médicale à bord et
on est pro vie et au québec
malgré tous les efforts qui essaient de
faire pour percer ici ça vaut lui nuire
énormément parce que il ya un large
consensus social la commission mourir
dans la dignité
déjà été assez fier du travail
d'ailleurs beefheart poitras partisans
qui avait été fait et ils vont trouver
ils vont pas comprendre je pense pas
trop d'émotion autour merci d'avoir
compris la tête de ce panel avoue 3
merci beaucoup en art n'est pas ça très
contente que les sujets autrefois salut